introduction to Sprites
for the benefit of tiny humans
greetings humans my name is Professor
luxcraft can you see me okay
good not all humans can see Sprites you
see but but clearly you are one of the
special ones now most humans don't even
know we Sprites exist but the truth of
it is Sprites are everywhere we Sprites
are the creators and guardians of
everything you humans would call the
natural world their clouds Sprites and
mountains Sprites and oh look there's
one now
a forest Sprite
you see didn't I tell you but that is
just the beginning
Sprites come in many different shapes
and sizes there are Forest Sprites who
make trees and dream Sprites to make
dreams and rabbit Sprites and Rain
Sprites and rock Sprites and bird
Sprites and time Sprites and Ice Sprites
and every Sprite has role to play in
creating things for the human realm but
of course that's only once they've
discovered what kind of sprite they are
destined to be young Sprites must go
through intensive training and learn how
to hone their Sprite Powers before they
can play their parts that's all I have
to tell you for now if you want to learn
more you'll have to come and visit us in
the everything Factory to get there
you'll need to find a portal
but where would you find one
I'll never tell
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]